hey 42 here the ancient Egyptians used
to rub deadmau5 paste on their teeth to
ease two fakes and in Elizabethan
England a popular remedy for warts was
to cut a mouse in half and apply it to
the offending spot in the Middle Ages
some doctors believes that like cures
like so when the black death hit which
was believed to be caused by deadly
vapors they were convinced that the cure
was to fart in a jar
the doctors urged people to store farts
in a jar and keep them in their homes
and when the plague appeared in their
neighborhood they were to take a whiff
of the jars contents highly popular in
medieval Europe euros Coupee was the
practice of diagnosing a patient by
examining their urine the doctors would
observe the patient urine smell
unconcealed even taste it on a similar
note at number four is urine therapy
some people throughout history believe
that drinking and even bathing in urine
is the key to good health and can cure
various ailments however unlike most of
the treatments in this video that's have
since died out urine therapy is still
widely used today despite there being
absolutely zero evidence that it can
cure anything Hitler was a hypochondriac
so his doctors injected his buttocks
with all kinds of substances one of
which was crystal meth witnesses claimed
the MEF adult Hitler stayed alert and
active throughout the day Albert Speer a
member of the Third Reich
considered Hitler's meth addiction as
one of the reasons for Hitler's rigid
tactics in the later stages of the war
such as not allowing troops to retreat
even under the most dire circumstances
in the 18th and 19th centuries to cure a
patient stutter doctors would cut off
half of the stutterers tongue the
practice is known as high
Glaus ectomy and it is still used today
but as a treatment for oral cancer it's
now done under general anesthesia but
back in the day it would have been
extremely painful procedure to undergo
and unsurprisingly it didn't work a lot
of patients simply bled to death today
arsenic is commonly known as a poison
but for centuries it has been used as a
medicine it is best known for being the
key ingredient in a supposed cure for
malaria uncivil 'us called Fowler's
solution that was widely used throughout
the late 18th century up until the 1950s
Victorian women also used arsenic as a
cosmetic in the 19th century mothers got
increasingly tired of disobedient
children keeping them up all night so to
aid distressed parents a series of
soothing syrups were invented and
marketed to mothers the syrup solution
sure worked in keeping children quiet
the only problem was it worked a little
too well
unbeknown to mothers the soups usually
contained a concoction of chloroform
codeine cannabis and heroin as well as
many other nasty substances in many
cases the children died from taking the
syrups however it wasn't until 1910 when
the New York Times published what the
syrups actually contain that the usage
declined in the 1940s if you were
mentally ill depressed or just didn't
fit into normal society for any reason
there is one answer lobotomy
the inventor of lobotomy Edgerton Moniz
who created the procedure in 1935 was
actually awarded a Nobel Prize for his
findings in 1949 although the reality
was considerably less glamorous a
lobotomy operation consisted of
rendering the patient unconscious for a
short time via a series of electrical
shocks to their brain the nurse or
doctor then jabbed an ice pick through
the upper eye socket of the patient and
pierced it through the skull using a
mallet until it hit the brain
the ice pick was then wiggled from side
to side in order to sever the
connections to the person's prefrontal
cortex the part of the brain that's
responsible for a person's personality
expression cognitive behavior
decision-making and social behavior
doctors believed if you remove this
section of the brain patient will be
cured of any mental illnesses anxiety
and depression parents even started
getting their kids lobotomized to fix
their bad behavior something we know
today as ADHD one of the youngest devil
lobotomy patients dually with 12 years
old
however lobotomies lost popularity
around 1967 when people realized that
shoving an ice pick through someone's
brain probably isn't a good idea after
one patient died of a brain hemorrhage
during the operation but they are still
performed today in extreme cases what
humans have been making holes in each of
the skulls for thousands of years
perhaps one of the oddest practices and
the oldest surgical procedure for which
we have ever found evidence of is
trepanning also known as trepanation it
is a strange practice of drilling a hole
in one skull - supposedly treat migraine
seizures and mental illness there is no
medical evidence to back a talk and not
surprisingly it's often made the
symptoms worse Neolithic skulls have
been found with trepanation holes in
them dating back as early as 6500 BC a
medical professional would never perform
this procedure today however some avid
supporters of this procedure still trip
on their own schools using stuff such as
power tools to this day thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2
you